all right vigo i wanted to start with
you because obviously you've worked with
david quite a few times now so it was
making me wonder what is something about
your collaboration that stayed
consistent even since day one and then
what's something about crimes of the
future that called for something a
little different well
beyond what we're doing
in terms of
you know telling a story
in a movie
um we're friends and there's a trust
that's been there
from the beginning so when you trust
your director
even if they're asking you to do
something really strange
or the scene
seems challenging in some way
if you trust that person
just
personally it helps
and it also helps if he's proven again
and again that the things he's asking
you to do he has a very good reason for
and he can explain them to you if you
need an explanation
so so you i'm willing to try things for
him that i might not so easily try
without
any questions asked at all you know for
someone else i have to follow that up
now of everything you have to experience
in crimes of the future what is like the
absolute peak in terms of strange things
he asked you to do that made you maybe
pause and think for a minute but then
jump in well it wasn't like the you know
the body kind of stuff or
even some of the
unusual kind of emotional transitions
it was
it was playing a character that was very
reactive
not
sometimes passive but not
not exactly passive just more
timid in a way
sort of contradictory you know he's very
secretive he's almost paranoid about his
physical and mental state
um
and yet his art the art that he performs
with his partner caprice
is all about
literally sharing his innermost physical
secrets in public performances so it's
like figuring out
what that contradiction is and
and how to play a character who's
basically reactive you know he's
reacting to what's happening to his body
to what his partner is doing
to
the public and to his environment and
how it affects them physically
so it was trying to get used to that
that was the most challenging really
okay all right i was uh reading that you
uh originally had been approached to
play the role of tim lin so like one
what was it about caprice that really
spoke to you but also what is it like
approaching a you know a master helmer
like david cronenberg and saying i know
you want me for this role but i think
it's best if i play this role
um
i was just like when i read the script i
i felt more um
i related more to to caprice
because there was like
there was something about the
relationship that she has with uh soul
tensor uh that i liked and um
and i i i love the
the love story
in the film
but um
[Music]
i could i would have played any any role
you know for david it's uh it's just you
know i just felt that i maybe had more
to say
with this role i would be totally down
to watch another version of this movie
where everybody roll swaps i kind of
like the sound of exercises like that
yeah i like i was i was i was actually
interested in a different role in this
movie in the beginning too and then he
said now you should play saul i like the
idea of playing uh and maybe it's
because i didn't know what to do with
this sort of reactive kind of character
i thought i'd rather play the
the fed you know the cop the part that
welket plays
um but he said no no you should play
this one
and and welcome did such a great job so
i mean i can't imagine someone else
anyway doing it
better um
and i would have been deprived if i'd
done that i wouldn't have been able to
play all these scenes with leia and and
i agree with her when i first read it
you know there's all these strange
things that happen in the story but in
the center there is this love story
there's a real
trusting
you know mutual
respect kind of relationship between
them that's quite tender
in the middle of this kind of hardcore
movie there's this very tender
vulnerable
love story your connection is really
like the beating heart and and a really
strong spine for the movie overall and
you know because of that but in general
i do always love talking about the value
of a good scene partner so for each of
you is there anything that the other did
for you onset as a scene partner that
you really appreciated and maybe even
helped you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without them well you never know
what you're gonna get when you work with
someone for the first time
you know i've had times where someone
said oh you're not going to like it
they're difficult or or you're going to
love it you never know until you're
there but
what i got
from you was that you're very generous
and you're also
brave
and so that encouraged me to
go for it and and
you know i much prefer no matter what
the story is about to have a good time
working
it's it's more fun and you usually do
better work if you're having if you're
enjoying what you're doing
and because most of our scenes are with
each other
the fact that we could laugh at things
and sometimes say do you know what that
was what was that i mean like i'm not
sure but he seems happy okay
no but there was a complicity
and
and and we were able to laugh at
ourselves and at the situation sometimes
which i think is healthy you know
especially when you're doing strange
scenes for me uh i mean to work with
viggo
i've heard terrible things about him
that he was like a nightmare to work
with so i was a bit scared
[Laughter]
and very respected
i was but
i was also i mean it's also the reason
why i i wanted to to be part of the film
is that i wanted to work with viggo
um
because i i i i love him as an actor
and as a human being as well but what i
love in in the process of um
filmmaking when you when you
work on a film is also the relationship
that you have with your
your
collaborators and it's in a way it's a
bit like
in the film
uh soul tenser and my character caprice
are together and they are
both performers
and so it's exactly what we had on set i
think uh and
i think the key when you work with with
someone in general is that to to um
because you you you are
very vulnerable when you act
you open you open up
uh in a way like in the movie
um and uh what i loved about vigo is
that he was he was very attentive
and uh and i think it's also
uh you have to listen
and uh we were i think we were like
really
like from the the minute from the minute
we met like we had like a connection
it's it's
and it's true that it's uh it's i mean
it's based on
also an intimate
um connection
that you have
and it will
it's it's
it helps and it's
what you see on the screen as well
it's about i mean cinema for me is also
about intimacy
so it's something that that we've
created together in a way it says mighty
powerful in the finished film so again
huge congratulations i could stay here
and ask you a million more questions but
they won't let me so congratulations and
enjoy the release